next thing
value value
okay value value take that in just
repeat it to yourself until it makes
sense
okay if you want to date a girl that has
nothing going on
then that's fine but please do not mix
in
people like me and my friends who have
something going on
with your other girls that have nothing
going on and by nothing going on i mean
this
i don't there is no job that is
unimportant there is no job that's not
valuable or that's not worthy it is
but if you want to mix in people like me
and people like my friends who are go
getters
who work really hard who make their own
money who are talented
skilled ambitious please don't mix us
in with the thotianas we don't want to
could you be
could you imagine being married to this
karen with her lecturing you like this
if you're not doing what she wants
pointing and sputtering and telling
you off that you're not fulfilling her
hopes wants dreams and desires
fellas women are women you know don't
don't uh don't hate them for it don't
love them too much for it they're just
women
they're they're all going to default to
baseline behaviors like this
she's she's saying value value you know
like she's a person of high value
i've got a job going on i've you know
i've got exposure
she's obviously a little high in herself
with her social media following and the
influence she might have with fox or fox
news or whatever that she does
but at the end of the day she's kind of
basic right like she's nothing that
special
what what value does your job or your
instagram following bring to my life you
know
men are success objects to women women
are beauty objects to men
uh you've been on the carousel you're
not a virgin what
what is this high value that you're
bringing to the table for me
you're talking about you know that that
ship has sailed
well that tells me that you've had a lot
of fun on that ship
oh boy let's let's keep going i'll be
there if that's what you want
find them please for the love of god do
not mix us
in with them because we don't want to be
there
and quite frankly we take it as an
insult if we find out that you are also
talking
to five tatianas who have nothing going
on people like
me and my friends are going to be
insulted by that
and there's almost really no coming back
from it okay
oh man um she's she's taking it as an
insult if a high value guy is talking to
her
and five other women at the same time i
wonder why that is
you know we already know that women
women are more than happy to share a
high value alpha they prefer to do that
than to be straddled with a faithful
loser
women spin plates by their nature
they're always dating multiple guys
simultaneously
so why is it that there's a new set of
rules today
just for tommy and she and you're going
to hear her say this at the end you know
guys message her all the time
how do i find a nice trad con woman like
you
um i'll let her unfold because i mean
she basically says enough to
to to distill this for you so if you
want that kind of a girl
the kind of girl who's just kind of
happy going through the motions of life
not really super ambitious hasn't really
found herself yet
doesn't really have a whole lot going on
super ambitious like
women don't share their pot of gold with
men men
share their pot of gold with women so
there's no value to me
to get involved with anybody that's got
four million followers on instagram or
as a commentator
on fox news you're just a public figure
with
uh an over inflated sense of entitlement
right now at this stage
going on other than she's pretty please
just go after them
and please do not mix us in we don't
want to be there
i promise you so value value
there's a lot of women out there that i
know that are my good friends who have
amazing jobs who work really hard
but who can't seem to find a decent guy
even if they go up in age
5 to 10 to 15 years because those guys
all want to be
with 21 year olds who have nothing going
on whoa did you hear that
did you hear that all the guys that she
and her girlfriends are talking to
want to be with 21 year olds i wonder
why that is
there is a sexual market value curve and
women hit their peak
21 22 23 after that they're on the
decline
men's value continues to go up past that
stage till about their late 30s like i
said earlier
men are success objects women are beauty
objects
this lady is going to be a chirping
karen in the next five to ten years
mark my words she might look pretty
today but mark my words
this is exactly where she's going
it's very unfortunate i don't think it's
going to be fulfilling
but i would say to the men out there try
to maybe find a woman that you can talk
to
communicate with might actually have her
[ __ ] together
might actually be ambitious and have
something going on or want to have
something going on
i don't care what she does she doesn't
have to be on tv she doesn't have to be
a phd
she doesn't have to be a television
producer she doesn't have to own her own
company but be ambitious
and have something going on those women
out there
are going to be a lot more fulfilling to
you you're actually going to enjoy your
time
and if you actually might want a
sustainable and healthy
and stable relationship that's probably
the kind of girl
you're going to need to find not the
tatianas
who just want to look cute and post
instagram stories
now i love a good instagram story y'all
know i do i love a good boomerang
i love a good whatever but if that's all
you do
men if that's all she does
probably houston we have a problem just
gonna let you in on a little
tip so she's making fun of other women
that are doing exactly what she does on
instagram
posting thottery look at me look at me
i'm over here guys
look at me
you